hello I'm Chrissy Teigen I'm here with
glamour UK and I'm about to review
British television naked let's have a
look at pink god water I can tell you
that I came here
yeah absolutely ladies a pink in the
middle rarer with his toes Ram my what
do you like to say if I don't do this
right don't what - I mean just to use
them up never know what those balls
could you cut up to 11 inches no oh but
like half grown in what modes is a woman
one mouth cubic that's a real turn-on
ana what I've never seen it so many like
close to each others like you forget
what the other one looks like when
there's someone else comes along I love
to use clotted cream in the back this
isn't the real isn't like he's an
accurate research dog Judith get in
there
I forgot the other person gets naked oh
I like them together the boner who is
getting a phone and she'd even pick the
biggest P P are they still together
trust me I'm like the queen of diggin
like I will find out everything about
these people I'll slide into her DMS we
were at the Corinthian such a beautiful
fancy hotel there were flowers
everywhere and it came in and I sat down
and I turn on the TV and the first thing
I saw her eosin balls and it was just so
wonderful there are Paris people there
are New York people for me I'm I'm a
London girl it's just like it's not a
big deal I love that you guys just do it
you put it out there and it's like I've
seen a lot of penises but I'm still like
I want to see things and not be so
floored by it
is he gonna just wanna say science yay
you've been gone around disgusted by
from between us yeah what I truly I
can't understand I'm sorry I have
captions on for a lot of shows i watch
so you just hear that clearly like
that's clear to you okay that's clear
that's so interesting you I ever gonna
get these two can take oh actually think
it this is real show what happens at the
end they win something
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay they're very fresh I was like
Adriana Lima so they're here to shake
things up just wearing the pool heels
John and I like to pick who we would
pick John liked was a Zoey
I like bluest wait all right confident
but this is only a weekend yeah how are
you jealous after like a week like they
get jealous after a day yeah do you want
me get it
What did he say oh my gosh
do you want me get like I am having
funny floors I'm not even in America we
call it flat flutters like butterflies
in your stomach
fanny is this what Orfeo knees are but
but if I go there and I say fanny style
I truly haven't like not been flirted
with for so long I can't imagine someone
being like gift-wrapped like I would
just die yeah it would not take much for
me to move on but I just appreciate that
they're also free and fine with
everything I mean more power to them